>> So, you may introduce yourself and your
company and what you're going to bring in
this conference now?
>> TANTOW: Yes, sure. And so, my name is Martin
Tantow. I'm co-founder and business lead of
3scale Networks. We're originally from Barcelona,
Spain but we just opened an office in Sunnyvale,
actually last year already. So, 3scale is
an API Management Solution. We provide this
is a [indistinct] way. And what we're presenting
and demoing here at Google I/O is actually
two applications. One is base and one is called
Appspot Image and is based on Python, hosted
on Google App Engine. And the other one is
a UN data project written in Java and hosted
on Google App Engine as well.
>> So, tell me a bit about your decision to
use App Engine for your apps?
>> TANTOW: Yes, sure. And so, we are actually
quite excited. I think, we think that Google
App Engine is quite a revolutionary tool.
For us critical is, it is highly scalable,
it's reliable. It is also cost effective to
certain limits. And so, it was for us basically
a no-brainer to look at Google App Engine
and host these two solutions on Google App
Engine. And so far we have been very successful
and very happy with the performance.
>> And so, do you have any particular war
stories you'd like to share or challenges?
>> TANTOW: Yeah, well, I try to. I have actually
not been the one who had actually developed--but
synching with our audio Opera team. They were--in
general they were quite happy. However, I
think, especially on the Java site, it seemed
to be not as smooth as they expected. Python
was fine. Except the fixed connection time-out
that they actually had problems with but the--on
the Java version it was more the data model
that they had problems with but I guess apart
from that, you know, they--we're quite happy
with the performance.
>> So, are you using App engines for production
now for, has it been bringing in money?
>> TANTOW: Yes, we actually do. We just started
with it. So, our Solution Appspot Image has
kind of a premium model. And so, there's a
free version but there's also a paid version.
And so, we are actually using our own billing
and payment solution for that. But yes, we
use Google App Engine for production and for
dollar product.
>> And so, what are your favorite App Engine
features?
>> TANTOW: Well, we're actually quite impressed
with the Dashboard in general and the graphics
and Analytics that you get there. In a way
they're quite complementary as well to our
own Analytics and monitoring that we provide
on our API management solution. We also liked
the versioning feature actually quite a bit.
The App Engine Launcher as well which actually
never failed and was actually quite good.
Man Cash feature to mention as well. And so,
quite some good features.
>> And so, what advice would you give to someone
who is a new developer on the just coming
App Engines?
>> TANTOW: Well, we would say that why would
you use a Google App Engine, why would you
use 3scale? I think it's certainly something
that works very well together. I would say
if you create applications on Google App Engine
think about having an API, make sure it is
scalable and usable and, you know, you created
it the right way and use App Engine and 3scale
together with it because our integration for
it actually works and we've tested it here
and demoed here at Google I/O.
>> And so, can you integrate the App Engine
with any other product services or websites?
>> TANTOW: Yeah, actually that's what I just
meant. And so, the 3scale service itself is
a soft space solution. It's hosted on other
services and actually we did that integration
with 3scale and our own API and it actually
does work very well. And so, yes, we have
done it in that sense.
>> And so, is there anything from I/O that
you're going to take with this on or that
you got really excited about here?
>> TANTOW: Taking away is a good question
I guess. Giving us the new G to, you know,
mobile phones. And so, yes, I'm going to take
something away. It probably means more like
kind of learning and so on. Certainly, yeah,
I mean, this morning Google Wave was certainly
a big hype. I was--I think we were all excited
when we heard yesterday. We go--we got like
Google phones and there was like, okay, the
next day it's going to be even better. And
so, the question was what can be better than
the Google phone, it was Google Wave and I
think it's going to be really, really a big
thing and we're very excited about that.
>> Well, thank you so much for talking with
us.
>> TANTOW: Thanks a lot.